[MUSIC PLAYING]
So we think of ourselves as
dynamic, autonomous creatures
that have agency and
free will, right?
We move about the world, and
things don't influence us
because we have free will.
We have the capacity to decide
at every moment who we are
and where we're going, right?
That is what we do.
Except when you look
deeper, you actually
find that mind,
that consciousness,
is in fact not necessarily
autonomous from the world
in which it dwells.
In other words, consciousness
is a co-production.
Consciousness is a collaboration
between subject and object.
Professor David Lenson writes
about this in his book.
So consider what that means.
It basically means there's not
just one type of consciousness,
right?
There is this notion that
it's person multiplied
by place multiplied by time
that reveals a garden of forking
paths of possible
consciousnesses,
of possible entities, and
that your consciousness is
mediated-- again, if you
think about what I'm saying--
by the spaces that we dwell.
In other words, the designs
that we create design us
in return, right?
Ontological design.
So what does that mean?
It means that the
people you hang out with
determine who you are.
It means that the
language you speak
sculpts your perception
of the world.
It means that the
culture in which you live
shapes your worldview.
It means that the people that
you meet meet you in return,
and thus affect you.
We are mediated beings.
The clothing that
we wear, uniforms,
can structure our
beliefs about the world.
I mean, even typography
can change how you think
and how you perceive it.
This notion that the
wallpaper of the mind
can influence reality so much,
can influence consciousness,
can influence perception, to the
degree that who and what we are
is determined by where we
are and where we dwell.
The wallpaper matters, right?
What is within is without.
What is without is within.
We're like the dragon
eating its own tail.
We're the ouroboros, OK?
We're Escher's hands.
The hand is drawing
the hand that's
drawing the original hand.
Whoosh.
That's us.
And again, what is the
takeaway of this idea?
That we can create
our own reality--
that our creative and
linguistics choices govern
our faith.
I design, therefore I become.
The vertigo of freedom-- pfew.
[MUSIC PLAYING]